c'est une mesure qui préviendra la
récidive et qui je l'espère sera
suffisamment dissuisive pour amener un
peu de d'apaisement de pacification sur
les réseaux
[Musique]
sociaux notre coyens ils rencontent
chaque jour de la sécurité sur TER ça
finit par Sapper leur confiance dans le
numérique et nous-même comme responsable
politique comme famille politique on ne
peut pas soutenir sans garantir à nos
concitoyens et en particulier à nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles et les
plus vulnérables pense à l'exposition
des de nos enfants même très jeunes à
des contenus pornographiques je pense à
à l'exposition de nous tous et toutes
aux campagnes de SMS fruduleux qu'on a
tous reçu de la part prétendument de la
sécurité sociale des impôts pour la
viget critère et qui nont comme seul
objectif de nous piller nos données
personnelles ou banqueures et pour ça et
bien le projet de loi Pr voit une peine
de bannissement des réseaux sociaux pour
les auteurs de harcèlement c'est une
mesure qui préviendra la récidive et qui
je l'espère sera suffisamment dissuisive
pour amener un peu de d'apaisement de
pacification sur les réseaux
[Musique]
sociaux